In one video, let's see if we're able to
set up a custom domain on a custom site.
Boom.
Look at that. You can see custom domain
is set up. Website is set up.
Cookie consent is set up. And we have
our chatbot. What services do you offer?
It tells you. Let's create an SEO
optimized website in a couple of minutes
using Rank Site AI. So, I'll be using
the local service business template, but
if you have a more general website, you
can use the general website template.
And I've already done my research, so
we're going to actually be creating a
website that's going to do comparison
and recommend the best tours in Niagara
Falls.
So, first let's go ahead. We're going to
take our It gave us a meta description,
so I'm actually going to use that as our
tagline here. And then we're going to
add in the business name. So, the
business name I was able to find
a exact match domain. So, on Namecheap,
I found the domain bestniagaratours.com.
So, I'm going to use that as our
business name. We're going to add in our
city. Then we're going to go ahead and
add in more information about this
business. So, I'm going to copy over
this full
drive here of this information. Go to
continue. And then we're going to add in
the services that we offer.
So, I've went ahead and added in some
services and some areas that we serve.
And for the logo, we actually already
generated a logo, so I'm going to paste
in that logo there. Our brand color, I
think we're pretty good on this brand
color. We're going to add We're going to
copy over our FormSpree endpoint here.
Head back over to Rank Site. Paste that
in.
And our Open Router has already been
established, so I'm going to go ahead
and publish our site. Okay, so after a
couple of minutes, our site has been
generated. So, we can actually go ahead
and take a look at the live site. So,
Best Niagara Tours, we can go ahead and
change these images we like, but as we
can see, we got a pretty good site here
that we can work with. So, again, we can
change all of these imagery.
Um we can change any copy here that we
like, but as you can see, we got our
location pages, we got our FAQs,
we get our services, we get our about
us. So, everything here is kind of set
for us to now be able to edit this site.
So, I'm going to go back over, we're
going to go to dashboard.
And what I'm going to do is now, I'm
going to start generating some of these
pages. So, I'm going to generate the
home.
I'm going to generate also the
uh side-by-side Niagara Tour
comparisons. We're going to generate the
best of tour rankings. We're also going
to generate the tours by departure and
city route guides. And we're also going
to generate two of these location pages.
So, those are all generating. I'm going
to head over to the content planner.
And I can also click generate post
ideas. And this is going to give me blog
post ideas that we can generate for this
specific article. So, we're generating a
few things at a time,
and that's going to allow us uh to be
able to get some real content onto this
website quicker. So, small group versus
coach bus Niagara Tours, which is worth
it, how much does a Niagara day tours
cost? So, we're going to create a draft
for this, and we're going to generate
images. Now,
and then we're going to generate the
article. Now, I like generating an
article because it gives us multiple
images that we can then use throughout
the website.
So, our homepage has been generated. We
can see the content here. We can
actually go ahead and change these
images as we like. And if we scroll
down, we can actually see that the
schema the schema markup here has been
generated. So, the schema has been
included into this webpage, and we have
custom, as you can see, custom FAQs as
well. So, we can go ahead and publish
this page
and I can actually send this directly to
be indexed, but I haven't connected my
custom domain, so I wouldn't go ahead
and do that right away. So, while that's
working, let's actually go ahead and
we're going to download Sorry, we're
going to buy our custom domain from
Namecheap. So, bestniagaratours.com,
we're going to add this to cart. We're
going to go to checkout
and I'll show you guys how easy this is.
So, as you can see, we're already
rolling. We've created our website,
we've created our structure, we've
created our pages.
We've already generated a blog post,
um and now we're going to actually buy
our domain and connect it over to our
website.
So, within a couple of minutes, um we
are up and ready to go. If we were to
use WordPress, uh you know, this would
take us hours and hours to kind of get
our theme going and to get everything
set up. So, let me just go to da da da.
Okay, so we have it here. Best Okay. So,
purchase is done.
We can set up the DNS for our domain.
Um Okay, let's go back over to our
account here. Let's go to our dashboard.
We're going to go to So, we have
bestniagaratours.com.
This is our domain. We're going to go to
manage and then we're going to go to
advanced DNS. Okay, so we have our
domain. We've just bought it. We're
going to head over to hosting and domain
So, settings, hosting and domain and now
we're going to connect our new domain
that we just bought. Okay, so
bestniagaratours.com.
Please add in save domain, connect
domain.
Give it a couple of seconds here.
Boom.
So, we see here, right? So, we're
Namecheap. We're going to copy over our
A record. So, A record
A record A record. Okay, so add new
record A record.
This is the IP address at
and then save.
Boom.
Add a new record.
We're going to add in our
C name. So, this is our C name.
And www, I believe that's what it was.
Yep.
And save.
And that is how easy it is to set up
your custom domain. We're going to give
that a couple of seconds. So, let's go
ahead and check the DNS status. So, our
domain is now connected and working. So,
we just built a website,
built pages, built our blog post, and
then we connected over our custom domain
to this site. And everything is working
perfectly. Right? So, again, let's go
over to our draft post. Here's our draft
post. We have a article here, beautiful
beautiful article here
with our custom images. Look at this
image right here.
Beautiful image.
We're going to then publish this.
Go back over to our pages. What I want
to do now, I want to change these
images. So, as you can see, now we have
new images that we can use. So, we can
publish this image.
So, for home page, I want to change
this.
We can change this to this image.
Save. Publish.
We can change this to another image
image.
So, we're just essentially updating the
images so they look good and they're
relevant. Like, they're not like, you
know, irrelevant images.
Right? So, everything is coming together
so quickly and so well. And what we can
also do is this is a new addition that
we've added, we can turn on our cookie
consent, and we can also turn on our
live chatbot. So, I'm going to save all
of this.
Let's go go and publish this now
to our website. So, now we should have
our custom domain working. We should
have our cookie consent working, our
chatbot working, and our website is
going to have our location and service
pages with custom imagery onto our
website all in record time. Okay, so
this is the moment of truth.
In one video, let's see if we're able to
set up a custom domain on a custom site.
Boom.
Look at that.
Custom domain has been set up. I hope
you guys can see that because
sometimes my
OBS isn't capturing, but you can see
custom domain is set up.
Website is set up.
Cookie consent is set up.
And we have our chatbot. What services
do you offer?
It tells you
how to get into contact with
you.
Boom.
Right? Guys, this is absolutely
game-changing stuff that we're doing
here. So, obviously we want to go ahead
and change those imagery around.
But if you see the actual services that
we generated, and this website looks
really, really good, right? Like
everything looks great.
And then we can actually go ahead, click
through that, the best of, and we can
read through the content here.
Everything is internally linked as well.
Right? Everything there's no
blank
404. Everything is internally linked.
FAQs, schema markup.
And we can go ahead if we go back over
to Rank Site here, we can actually go
ahead to these pages.
Let's go to these pages, and then we can
index this page directly over to Google.
So,
as you guys saw, within a couple of
minutes we're able to set up this
website. Now, if we wanted to, we can
then set up analytics.
I've already done a video of that where
you can set up your Google Analytics and
your Google Search Console. It's very,
very simple to do. But, if you wanted to
set up your Google Analytics, just head
over to tracking and scripts, and then
you just enter in
your custom
uh script for your Google Analytics, and
that is it. Your Google Analytics will
be set up and it will be working. But,
again, guys,
I hope you're impressed because I am. As
you can see, within a couple of uh
minutes, we're able to generate this
fully functional website that looks
good. And also, I forgot to mention, it
is mobile optimized as well. So, as you
can see, it is responsive. So, if I make
it smaller, it looks great. If I make it
bigger, it looks great as well. So, it's
responsive on any device.
It's HTML.
Let's actually go ahead and do one thing
quickly before we end today's video.
Let's go ahead and test the page speed
index.
So, we're going to see how this website
is loaded, how it's uh viewed by Google
to see how indexable it is. But, again,
as you guys saw, we were able to
generate this website in a couple of
minutes with our cookie set, with our
chatbot, um with
internal linking as well. And also, I
forgot, we created a blog post. Look at
our blog post here. Boom.
Beautiful, beautiful blog post.
Beautiful blog post.
Go back over to our page speed insights.
90 performance, three out of three
agentic browsing. 91 performance. And we
need to do some little improvements are
on our agentic our browsing for our
desktop. But, as you can see, these page
insights are really, really impressive.
So, again, hope that you guys enjoyed
today's video. I definitely recommend
getting the lifetime deal for Rank Math.
It's not going to be here forever. There
is a very steep discount discount
because we are really really early, but
as you can see it's very impressive.
I'll see you guys in the next video.
Take care.